INVESTIGATION WITH ANONYMOUS
SOURCES AND LEAKING.
SIT TIGHT, BREAKING UP, WE
HAVE A LOT TO COVER IN
TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUED TO
PILE UP ONE MASSIVE WIN AFTER
ANOTHER.
AHEAD, OF COURSE, OF THE
ALL-IMPORTANT MIDTERM
ELECTIONS IN 2018 THIS YEAR.
TRUMP NOW HAS UNDENIABLE,
AMAZING RECORD OF PROMISES
KEPT AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
BY THE WAY, EVERY REPUBLICAN
CAN NOW RUN ON THE THINGS THAT
HE HAS DONE AND THIS CAN NO
LONGER BE IGNORED.
TODAY IN ISRAEL, THE PRESIDENT
KEPT A MAJOR CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
IVANKA TRUMP, JARED KUSHNER,
STEVEN MNUCHIN, OTHER TOP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
UNVEILED THE NEW EMBASSY IN
ISRAEL'S TRUE CAPITAL.
IT'S CALLED JERUSALEM.
THE PRESIDENT EMPHASIZES THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS HISTORIC
MOMENT IN A VIDEO MESSAGE TO
THE AUDIENCE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: TODAY,
JERUSALEM IS THE SEAT OF
ISRAEL'S GOVERNMENT.
IT IS THE HOME OF THE ISRAELI
LEGISLATURE AND THE SUPREME
COURT AND ISRAEL'S PRIME
MINISTER AND PRESIDENT.
ISRAEL IS A SOVEREIGN NATION
WITH THE RIGHT LIKE EVERY
OTHER SOVEREIGN NATION TO
DETERMINE ITS OWN CAPITAL.
YET FOR MANY YEARS WE FAILED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE OBVIOUS.
THE PLAIN REALITY THAT
ISRAEL'S CAPITAL IS JERUSALEM.
ON DECEMBER 6, 2017, AT MY
DIRECTION, THE UNITED STATES
FINALLY AND OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED JERUSALEM AS THE
TRUE CAPITAL OF ISRAEL.
TODAY WE FOLLOW THROUGH ON
THIS RECOGNITION AND OPEN OUR
EMBASSY IN THE HISTORIC AND
THE SACRED LAND OF JERUSALEM.
WE ARE ALL OPENING IT MANY,
MANY YEARS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
>> Sean: THE ISRAELI PRIME
MINISTER A MAN WHO I SAID FOR
MANY YEARS WITH INCREDIBLE
MORAL CLARITY, BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU, HE ALSO ATTENDED
THE MONUMENTAL EVENT.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE TALKED
ABOUT HIM KEEPING HIS WORD AND
HIS PROMISES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LAST DECEMBER, PRESIDENT
TRUMP BECAME THE FIRST WORLD
LEADER TO RECOGNIZE JERUSALEM
AS OUR CAPITAL.
TODAY, THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA IS OPENING THE EMBASSY
RIGHT HERE IN JERUSALEM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT TRUMP,
FOR HAVING THE COURAGE TO KEEP
YOUR PROMISES.
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND THANK YOU ALL FOR MAKING
THE ALLIANCE BETWEEN AMERICA
AND ISRAEL STRONGER THAN EVER.
>> Sean: THERE IS A REASON
THEY ARE SO THANKFUL FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BOLD
ACTIONS.
FOR DECADES WE HAVE HAD ONE
U.S. PRESIDENT AFTER ANOTHER
PROMISING OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO OPEN AN EMBASSY
IN JERUSALEM.
BUT THEY NEVER DELIVERED.
THEY BROKE PROMISES.
WE SEE WHAT THE PRESIDENT WILL
DO, HE DOES.
IT'S GOOD POLITICS, TOO.
KEEP YOUR WORD.
THIS IS HISTORY IN THE MAKING.
EVEN SENATOR CHUCKY SCHUMER
COULDN'T HELP BUT PRAISE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND SAID THE
MOVE IS LONG OVERDUE AND IT
WAS.
NOT ONE DEMOCRAT ATTENDED THE
EVENT.
GOD FORBID THEY SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT EVEN A LITTLE BIT.
REMEMBER JOE MANCHIN TRIED TO
STAND FOR A SECOND.
WHILE ISRAEL IS CELEBRATING
THE HISTORIC DEVELOPMENT, AND
HAMAS PREDICTABLY CARRYING OUT
BLOODY PROTESTS THAT LEAD TO
THE DEATH OF OVER 50
PALESTINIANS AND 1,000
INJURED.
THE HAMAS-INSPIRED PROTESTERS
HAVE BEEN SETTING THINGS ON
FIRE, THROWING FIRE BOMBS AND
STONES AT ISRAELI SOLDIERS.
THREE PALESTINIANS WERE KILLED
AFTER TRYING TO PLANT A BOMB.
IT'S EVIL IN OUR TIME AND
NOBODY WANTS TO SEE IT BUT
IT'S ALL TOO PREDICTABLE.
THE MEDIA RARELY REMINDS YOU
THAT THE CHARTER CALLS FOR THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE STATE OF
ISRAEL.
HAMAS PAYS THE FAMILY OF
TERRORISTS THAT GET KILLED
TRYING TO INFLICT PAIN AND
SUFFERING ON ISRAEL.
AMERICANS, TOO.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO DEFEND
ITSELF JUST LIKE ISRAEL HAS
THE RIGHT FOR JERUSALEM TO BE
THE CAPITAL.
ISRAEL IS NOT THE ONLY PLACE
THAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
IS MAKING SERIOUS PROGRESS.
MORE DEVELOPMENTS RELATING TO
NORTH KOREA AND KIM JONG UN
AND WHAT IS NOW THE MAKING YET
OF ANOTHER CONCESSION AHEAD OF
HIS MEETING AND HIS SUMMIT
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP NEXT
MONTH IN SINGAPORE.
LITTLE ROCKET MAN IS NOW
INVITING JOURNALISTS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD TO WATCH
DESTRUCTION OF THE TEST SITE.
EVEN MORE EVIDENCE THAT
TRUMP'S PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH
POLICY IS MORE THAN WORKING.
WE HAVE GONE FROM NORTH KOREA
FIRING MISSILES OVER JAPAN,
THREATENING GUAM, THREATENING
THE CONTINENTAL U.S., HAWAII
AND THE REST OF THE WORLD.
NOW WE'VE GOT LITTLE ROCKET
MAN WALKING ACROSS THE D.M.Z.,
MEETING WITH SOUTH KOREA'S
PRESIDENT R LEASING THREE
AMERICAN HOSTAGES LAST WEEK
AND IT DIDN'T INVOLVE ANY CASH
OR CARGO PLANES FULL OF CASH.
THERE IS ONE KEY FACTOR IN
THIS.
THAT IS THE PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE FORCED NORTH KOREA HAND AND
THE POLICY CONTINUES TO WORK.
WE ARE LEARNING THE NEW
DETAILED ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT
WILL COME UP AT THE JUNE
MEETING.
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER JOHN
BOLTON IS SAYING MANY ISSUES
ARE ON THE TABLE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> ON THE DENUCLEARIZATION
SIDE ITSELF, THAT MEANS ALL
ASPECTS OF THE NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
CLEARLY THE BALLISTIC MISSILE
PROGRAM AS WITH IRAN, WITH THE
INTENTION OF A DELIVERY SYSTEM
FOR THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THAT HAS TO GO.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
CHEMICAL AND THE BIOLOGICAL
PROGRAMS AS WELL.
THE PRESIDENT WILL RAISE OTHER
ISSUE.
SOUTH KOREAN CITIZENS
KIDNAPPED.
>> Sean: TRUST BUT VERIFY.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
WHO HAS BEEN MEETING WITH KIM
JONG UN.
HE MET HIM TWICE IS ALSO
LAYING OUT SOME OF THE DETAILS
ABOUT A POSSIBLE PLAN FOR THE
PENINSULA TO DENUCLEARIZE THE
WHOLE AREA.
IT WOULD BE AMAZING IF IT
HAPPENED.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS IS PRIVATE SECTOR
AMERICANS COMING IN.
NOT THE U.S. TAXPAYER.
THE PRIVATE AMERICANS TO BUILD
UP THE ENERGY GRID.
TO WORK AND DEVELOP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALL THE THINGS THEY NEED.
TO EAT MEAT AND HAVE HEALTHY
LIVES.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS IF WE GET
THE COMPLETE, VERIFIABLE,
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH
KOREA THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
OFFER IN SPADES.
THE EYES ARE WIDE OPEN WITH
RESPECT TO RISKS BUT IT'S OUR
HOPE CHAIRMAN KIM WANTS TO
MAKE A STRATEGIC CHANGE.
IF HE IS PREPARED TO DO THIS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PREPARED TO
ASSURE IT'S SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION.
>> Sean: KEYWORDS OF
SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO ARE
"COMPLETE, VERIFIABLE,
IRREVERSIBLE
DENUCLEARIZATION."
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISN'T JUST
GOING TO TAKE HIM AT HIS WORD
LIKE BILL CLINTON DID WITH HIS
FATHER.
IF KIM JONG UN WANTES THE
CRUSHING SANCTIONS TO BE LIFT
AND THE MILITARY OFF HIS COAST
AGAIN, IF HE DOESN'T WANT
THAT, HE WILL HAVE TO PROVE HE
IS COMPLETELY DESTROYED THE
NUCLEAR CAPABILITY.
THIS IS RONALD REAGAN'S POLICY
OF TRUST BUT VERIFY MEANS IN
ACTION.
WE ARE FOLLOWING ANOTHER STORY
FROM "THE HILL'S" JOHN SALMON
SALMON -- JOHN SOLOMON WHO IS
GOING TO JOIN US.
THE HEADLINE IS MUELLER MAY
HAVE A CONFLICT AND IT LEADS
DIRECTLY TO A RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
ACCORDING TO SOLOMON IN 2009,
MUELLER WAS INVOLVED WITH A
PLAN IN A RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE.
BY THE WAY, I DON'T OPPOSE
THIS.
I'LL BE CLEAR AND ESPLAIN
LATER TO LITERALLY RESCUE AN
F.B.I. AGENT.
ROBERT LEVINSON.
HE HAS BEEN MISSING FOR 11
YEARS.
IN EXCHANGE FOR THIS, THE
BILLIONAIRE WAS WILLING TO
SPEND $20 MILLION OF HIS OWN
MONEY AS PART OF THE OPERATION
AND HE WAS GIVEN A SPECIAL
VISA.
THE DIFFICULT PART IS THE
HYPOCRISY BECAUSE THIS IS THE
SAME RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE THAT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
INVESTIGATING IN THE RUSSIAN
PROBE BUT THEY KEPT HIS NAME
OUT OF THE INDICTMENT OF PAUL
MANAFORT.
THEY ARE TELLING JOHN SOLOMON
THAT THE PREVIOUS RELATIONSHIP
WITH MUELLER IS A MASSIVE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AS IT
RELATES TO THE MUELLER PROBE.
WE DID REACH OUT TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR A
STATEMENT BUT THEY DON'T LIKE
ME OVER THERE.
THEY DIDN'T COMMENT.
JAPAN SOLOMON WILL -- JOHN
SOLOMON WILL JOIN US WITH THE
DETAILS.
YET ANOTHER SETBACK FOR
MUELLER.
TWO FRIDAYS AGO, JUDGE T.V.
ELLIS III CALLED THIS
INVESTIGATION OUT AS A WITCH
HUNT TO GET TO CHARGES AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT.
ANOTHER JUDGE PICKING APART
THE INDICTMENT OF THE RUSSIAN
NATIONALS.
TONIGHT WE HAVE MORE
INCREDIBLE INVESTIGATION THAT
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION IS
IMPLODING.
A RUSSIAN COMPANY INDICTED BY
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL, REMEMBER,
MUELLER DIDN'T THINK ANYONE
WAS GOING TO RESPOND TO THIS
IS CALLING THE CHARGES
BASELESS AND IN COURT SAYING
MUELLER AND HIS HACKS HAVEN'T
EVEN SHOWN THAT THE COMPANY
INTENTIONALLY BROKE THE LAW.
AND A WEBSITE TONIGHT IS
REPORTING THAT THE ATTORNEY
FOR THE RUSSIAN COMPANY WANTS
TO SEE MUELLER'S SECRET GRAND
JURY INSTRUCTIONS WHICH HE
WOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO SEE.
THE DAILY WIRE IS OUT WITH A
REPORT SAYING THAT THE COURT
TRANSCRIPTS, GUESS THIS, SHOWS
THAT MUELLER INDICTED A
RUSSIAN COMPANY THAT DID NOT
EXIST AT THE TIME.
A LAWYER FOR THE COMPANY SAID
YOUR HONOR, WE ARE DEALING
WITH A SITUATION OF THE
GOVERNMENT INDICTING THE
PROVERBIAL HAM SANDWICH.
IT DIDN'T EXIST AS A LEGAL
ENTITY AT THE TIME IN THE
GOVERNMENT.
AT A LATER TIME IF THEY COULD
SHOW IT DID EXIST WE'D
PROBABLY REPRESENT THEM BUT
FOR PURPOSES TODAY, WE DON'T
REPRESENT THEM.
WOW!
ANDY McCARTHY QUOTED TO SAY
FROM NATIONAL REVIEW ONLINE
ONE THING YOU NEVER WANT TO DO
IS INDICT IN A CASE YOU ARE
NOT PREPARED TO TRY.
CLEARLY MUELLER'S TEAM WAS NOT
PREPARED.
THEY WERE CAUGHT FLAT FOOTED
AND THE INVESTIGATION IS
FALLING APART IN A SPECTACULAR
FASHION AND THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA IS NOT TELLING YOU ANY
OF THIS.
THE REST OF THE DEEP STATE IS
PUT ON NOTICE AS THEY CONTINUE
TO BE EXPOSED.
YOU SAW THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
I WAS OFF FRIDAY.
KIM STRASSEL IS RAISING
CONCERNS ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE F.B.I. IS PLANTING A
MOLE INSIDE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
OKAY.
WHAT IF IT WAS HILLARY?
IT'S A STUNNING NEW
DEVELOPMENT, ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE F.B.I. THEN LATER
HELPING HILLARY WHEN WE KNOW
THAT IT IS INCONTROVERTIBLE,
THE EVIDENCE IS OVERWHELMING
SHE COMMITTED FELONIES AND
CRIMES AND OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE FULLY INVESTIGATED.
THAT MEANS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE NEEDS TO GET UP AND
SEND OVER THE SUBPOENA
DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS A PATTERN PLAYING OUT.
WE HAVE SEEN SEVERE FISA
ABUSES.
THE F.B.I. LYING TO MULTIPLE
JUDGES ABOUT THE CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
WITH RUSSIAN SOURCES PAID FOR
BY AND WORKED ON BY A FOREIGN
NATIONAL.
THEY GOT WARRANTS TO SPY ON A
MEMBER OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE RAMPANT, RIDICULOUS 350%
UP-TICK BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND UNMASKING
IN THE 2016 ELECTION YEAR.
THEN THE CRIMINAL LEAKING THAT
TOOK PLACE.
MICHAELFLIP -- MICHAEL FLYNN
IS ONLY ONE EXAMPLE.
HIS NAME WAS LEAKED TO THE
NEWS MEDIA.
IT'S BEYOND DISTURBING AND WHY
THE DEEP STATE IF WE CARE
ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW, THE
EQUAL APPLICATION OF THE LAW
AND THE CONSTITUTION, THE
PEOPLE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
SOME MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
TRYING TO DO THAT.
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY IS
DEMANDING ANSWERS ABOUT
COMEY'S CONFLICTING TESTIMONY
OVER MICHAEL FLYNN'S INTERVIEW
OVER THE F.B.I. AGENTS.
HE TOLD CONGRESS HE DIDN'T
THINK THAT MICHAEL FLYNN LIED
BUT THAT IS WHAT MUELLER
CHARGED FLYNN WITH.
THEN REMEMBER, THIS
INFORMATION, THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND OTHERS AT THE D.O.J., THEY
FOUGHT TO KEEP REDACTED IN THE
NAME OF NATIONAL SECURITY WHEN
CLEARLY IT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH NATIONAL SECURITY.
LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN
SLOWWALKING, THEY ARE
STONEWALLING AND THE D.O.J. IS
DEPLOYING ONE TACTIC AFTER
ANOTHER TO PREVENT CONGRESS
FINDING OUT THE TRUTH ABOUT
HOW CORRUPT THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN FROM
DAY ONE.
AND THE ABUSE OF THE FISA LAWS
HAVE BEEN AND PUTTING THE FIX
IN FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES, THEN
TREY GOWDY NOW SAY THE D.O.J.
IS TRYING TO DISCREDIT THE
INVESTIGATION BY USING
ANONYMOUS SOURCES TO ATTACK A
G.O.P. STAFFER WHO HELPED
EXPOSE SURVEILLANCE ABUSES.
THIS IS PATHETIC.
IF THE GOVERNMENT USES THE
POWER TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE
AND TURNS THEM ON US, WE DON'T
HAVE A COUNTRY ANYMORE.
IT PROVES THAT THE D.O.J. IS
CLEARLY HIDING SOMETHING.
ROD ROSENSTEIN BEGGED PAUL
RYAN NOT TO TURN OVER
INFORMATION ABOUT FISA ABUSES.
INSTEAD OF TURNING OVER THE
DOCUMENTS, CONGRESS HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE OF
OVERSIGHT.
THEY ARE JUST ATTACKING THE
CONGRESSMAN.
FINALLY TONIGHT, REVEALING
REPORT FROM THE WASHINGTON
COMPOST.
TRUMP SUCCESSES ARE SO
UNDENIABLE AT THIS POINT EVEN
THE LIBERAL MAINSTREAM MEDIA
IS STRUGGLING TO DENY AND SPIN
THEM.
NOW DEMOCRATS ARE REALLY
SCARED BECAUSE THE 17-POINT
GENERIC MID-TERM CONGRESSIONAL
BALLOT LEAD HAS DISAPPEARED.
EVEN FAKE NEWS CNN HAS A POLL
WITHIN THE MARGIN OF ERROR.
AND IS ONE POINT OF THE
REUTER'S POLL.
WE SECURED THE RELEASE OF
THREE AMERICAN HOSTAGES, WE
DIDN'T PAY FOR IT.
WE CAPTURED THE TOP FIVE MOST
WANTED ISIS LEADERS.
WE ENDED THE HORRIFIC URANIUM
NUCLEAR DEAL.
SET A DATE FOR A SUMMIT WITH
LITTLE ROCKET MAN IN NORTH
KOREA.
THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS AT AN
ALL-TIME LOW IN THIS COUNTRY.
14 STATES HAVE ALL-TIME LOW.
HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT AT
ALL-TIME LOW.
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE AT
ALL-TIME LOW AND OVERALL
UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT AN ALL-TIME
LOW SINCE 2000.
THE CNN POLL SHOWS WE HAVE
OPTIMISM AT THIS COUNTRY AT AN
11-YEAR HIGH.
THE ATLANTA FEDERAL RESERVE
FORECASTING THE SECOND QUARTER
ECONOMIC GROWTH AT WHOPPING
4.1%.
THE MID-TERMS ARE GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, NOT THIS
FALSE, ALL THIS NOISE, ALL